[Musique]
vous avez déjà goûté à un petit animal
si j'étais je te rassure nous sommes à
sainte anne des monts au centre
d'interprétation des ressources maritime
du saint laurent
exploramer plus fermé samedi puisque le
homard les gens avaient envie de goûter
parce que quand les gens font la visite
guidée à chaque fois qu'on arrive devant
un nouveau poisson la question que tous
les gens pensaient pas se marcher dessus
sans goût de quoi faire découvrir les
espèces méconnues du saint laurent
c'est une des missions d'exploration et
pour inciter restaurateurs et les
poissonniers à proposer ces drôles de
poissons et fruits de mer sandra
gauthier a créé il y a dix ans la
certification fourchette bleue mais
chaque vin en gaspésie avec sa mère en
2004 je savais bien que manger en
gaspésie du saumon dans les restaurants
on mangeait de la crevettes tigrées dans
les restaurants on mangeait plein de
poissons importés
[Musique]
on a choisi d'adhérer à la fourchette
bleue pour ce qu'on trouvait très
important de valoriser des produits les
produits d'ici les produits de la mer
les produits qui fait sous-exploité les
produits qui étaient méconnus
[Musique]
vous
alors ça c'est l'homme de mme langhoff
saisir à la poêle avec le à la maison du
pêcheur on était fourchette bleue bien
avant fourchette bleue
dès l'ouverture de la maison du pêcheur
le 9 juillet 85 nous avions à ce moment
là un consommé aux ags
on parle de potage aux oursins on parle
de l'humain on parle de ré 10 yona le
filet de loket aux échalotes la loket
est un poisson valorisé par crochète
bleus mais elle demeure introuvable pour
le consommateur en ces deux espaces
surtout pour la liqueur qu'on retrouve
dans les casiers à homards sauf que les
pêcheurs de homard en pole droit de
ramener la look est abusive celui ci
c'est quoi emilie fer zinc ou de poisson
c'est une charte qui s'obtient donc et
ferme
ça a un goût qui pourrait s'apparenter
un peu à la mort ou à la broye
[Musique]
ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a fait des
moules façon à rien puis on est idéal
pour avoir le plus coté fourchette bleue
avec les produits qu'ils me proposent
fait qu on va goûter une moule aux
halles avec une bonne frite
au bistro bar de brise bise à gaspé le
patron simon poirier adhère volontiers
au programme fourchette bleue c'est ce
carnet un fourchette bleue le monde qui
voit c'est que c'est des espèces qui
sont un peu plus rare qu'on retrouve
moins dans nos assiettes
il ya du monde qui vont être allumés de
goûter à ce un programme pas si simple à
mettre en pratique il ya des productions
un peu plus difficile à avoir accès mais
il y en a d'autres comme les mois nous
facilement on en est à gaspé également
de flétan durant la saison
les algues c'est donc une grosse demande
au niveau des zags ses décors des super
bons mais les prévisions mans et traite
un peu difficile ah ouais l'offre est
moins grande la demande est moins grande
alors il y en a pas beaucoup sur le
marché mais ce serait intéressant de
pouvoir une offre à voir se produire
parce qu'on pourrait les présenter aux
autorités ont proposé locaux aussi
mettre en valeur une espèces méconnues
c'est tout un défi s'implique beaucoup
de monde de la pêche à l'assiette
il faut que les pêcheurs ramènent labour
droit il faut que les usines achète la
baudroie il faut que les unes l'avant
dans une poissonnerie donc tout cas une
poissonnerie qu'ils l'achètent pillent
la poissonnerie avoir lâché ses pains
consommateurs qui veulent acheter au
bout au droit couteau sébaste des
espèces pourtant délicieuse encore trop
absente de nos tables parce que
majoritairement exporter
on a énormément de poissons ne marque
pas vers l'étranger très peu qui reste
ici ailleurs c'est bien pays ils sont
prêts à payer pour du produit haut de
gamme nous le québécois on n'est pas
habitués à payer pour des poissons haut
de gamme
on nous fait manger du tilapia dupont
gazeuse à cravate gris clés du produit
pas de gamme en fait depuis dix ans le
programme fourchette bleue progresse
lentement mais sûrement et appose son
logo partout au québec
la baudroie maintenant on peut dire que
c'est un succès il n'y a plus une bo
droit qui se passe dans le saint laurent
donc s'il faut s'assurer que le
consommateur va la demande et donc qu'il
ya une attente quelles listes d'attentes
dans quel que soit le turbo de plus en
plus demandés mangés par les québécois
avant on faisait que exporter le turbo
donc on y voit espèce par espèce se
rendre compte en fait qu'on pouvait pas
prendre les quarante espèces fourchette
bleue de front il faut faire des focus
je pense qu'ils ne demandent que les
gens sont de plus en plus informés les
gens veut faire des découvertes
lorsqu'il sonne salima
on est prêt aujourd'hui acheter une
bouteille d'huile d'olive à 40 $ parce
que c'est la meilleure mais on n'est pas
prêt à payer un poisson pour la qualité
qu'on a ici donc des fois il faut
remettre les choses en perspective peut
se dire que on a un produit de qualité
il faut le voir comme ça c'est un
produit festif sans produit le plus
naturel et qui proviennent 6
[Musique]